weird
60 oh that's good that's i'm optimistic
so weird yeah
oh my god john you did it hey you did it
john
youtube was a [ __ ] about this you know
what i love
real life are we live can you guys
confirm this for us
somebody said thwipster said finally oh
my god i
did it i'm gonna take that as
verification holy [ __ ]
i i love technology because it really is
like on silicon valley where like
youtube just updated their live
streaming uh
i guess they updated their their
dashboard thingy
and it you can't access it without being
shown a a thing that says like hey i
assume you've never used this before
set up a stream that's the only option
you have is just to set up a new stream
and uh like even when i did that and set
up a new stream it just took me right
back there so
youtube is having brain problems today
but we're here we did it and while john
was doing that i was just on instagram
not thinking of
many ideas of what to do did you did you
get any good likes did you like anybody
else
i don't know so um our lighting is uh
even worse than it normally is today and
the reason
here's the reason why um so apparently
uh
right now it's over 100 degrees where
we're at and uh this room is generally
already pretty hot as it is
so we usually have the ac blasting but
dwp
department of water power put out a
statement uh
specifically to everyone in this three
mile radius that there's been power
outages due to overusage of ac so we
can't even really use
the uh ac right now so we're like
we have to use less lights today john
and i both have
ice packs on us yes so we're just trying
to keep cool right now
mine's actually in this room i'm gonna
perch it in my lumbar support right now
we're still live right if you can
confirm that for us that would be great
any chance you can just do just to be
like you're still alive
oh claudia bowling says hello i'm gonna
take that as a good sign
erica says we're live josh irish says we
rock i'm gonna say that
means we live that's right hello jaby
kowai thanks lloyd i'm glad you liked
our review
on uh project power oh a movie that a
lot of people don't seem to really like
that's it's my it might be my favorite
so far of those
netflix action movies it's 100 is i
liked it more than
bright and the old guard so there you go
hey eric horseman
claudia's here justin what's up deontay
how's it going tm
josh okay thank god oh life is much
better now we're good
jaby thinks we're alive and if he thinks
we're live he knows yes
okay good happy belated birthday thanks
jaby yeah
all right so today's theme after many
minutes of
explaining a bunch of nonsense to you
guys in fact i'll just i'll give you a
glimpse into our world
this is i cannot bypass this and it says
we're live
it literally says we are alive and i
cannot bypass it to get us to the live
control room so
if there's anything clunky in this
stream we'll have a slightly different
setup for how to showcase your uh
comments and contributions and whatnot
but should be smooth
awesome um okay so i thought for today's
stream
uh that we could do movies and shows
that could be remade into a different
genre
and uh reason being fresh prince of
bel-air is not the first one to do it
it's not they're not the first ones to
remake into a completely different genre
um hey i just want to get this out of
the way i'm not sure how i feel about
fresh prince being rebooted into a
trauma i feel like it could work
um to a certain degree but at the same
time i'm like i'm not sure
it really can you know i i feel like it
has to have has to be a dramedy
especially if you're gonna call fresh
prince of bel-air if you're if you're
calling it the same thing and you have
that name association
for such a popular show i'm really not
sure uh
if if it'll work well yeah because my my
issue becomes
i feel like the theme song is so
ubiquitous
that a that just doesn't strike me as a
dream or it should be a hardcore drama
and have the same theme
there's total contrast yeah like all
these images of will really getting beat
no but uh the thing is it's like so tied
to that specific
cast like is it coming back with any of
the or like was will smith doing it
oh will smith is producing it like i i'm
not going to say
it wouldn't work but the pitch to me
like i would believe a spin-off drama
could work
like fresh prince as a concept they just
need to find like the greatest
ensemble ever to do it otherwise it's
just going to be
sort of like oh you know it's not will
smith
yeah that's true so i'm i'm curious
though all right
so hey anissa's in the chat so is erica
tuesday
um so uh erica thinks we should do a
poolside broadcast someday
one of these days that'd be fun it would
be awesome um
so john do you have one in mind do i
have one in
mind i do okay let's hear it
well i mean this one i feel like is kind
of cheating but it's it's long been a
dream of mine ever since
i can't remember when i first came up
with this but it's long been a dream of
mine to make one of those like april
fool's style
trailers where it's not really revealed
like
you start to put it together halfway
through and then once it's revealed at
the very end with the title you're like
ah which is like i would love to do home
alone but
saw you know because uh i remember uh
in a college music class i took a music
and film class it was when it hit the
me the most because all they did no
somebody didn't even put a new music
track over it whoever brought the clip
in
they just played it without the music
and only the sound effects they somehow
were able to have it that way and it was
even disturbing just
that way okay and ever since then i've
been fascinated with the idea of like uh
yeah
coming up with some kind of uh genre
bent but i feel like that's a pretty
easy one to kind of that is an easy one
john
so come on give us a more challenging
one everyone says home alone
do they yeah man there's been so many
home alone reboot trailers
lana's in the chat sassy horror they've
been rebooted as a horror
i would love to do a reboot of like a
friend's or how i met your mother
but take seriously the more broad
elements
so like barney is like sued for sexual
harassment immediately
and it just becomes this like really
dark like it starts as a sitcom but
pretty soon
all the consequences start to descend
and then it becomes
like this show about people trying to
learn to stop just joking about
everything constantly and uh yeah i
would want to spin it off into some kind
of
surreal dark like meta drama that's
that's
like if you gave me the chance to do a
tv show like that that's
probably what i would want to do i said
it in last week's live stream i'd
love to see a follow-up to friends that
focuses
on ross and rachel who are going through
a nasty divorce it's inspired by
marriage story
and you see that this this this couple
that we've idolized on television
is really not a healthy couple at all
another one that i think a children's
movie that i absolutely think could be a
horror movie
mary poppins definitely and this is
tough
oh someone like mary poppins and mrs
doubtfire but
yeah mrs doubtfire could be uh a totally
creepy psychological thriller a domestic
about a guy who's obsessively desperate
to get back to his kids but is not
willing to obey the law go through legal
ways and then dresses up as a woman
and then he can become nissa's down fire
by the eddy as like a
uh a whole thing about him where he's
he's he
loses a sense of identity yeah yeah he
has gender reassignment like
and then you could make it like sleep
away camp where it's like a schlocky b
movie that all of a sudden has a twist
that makes you think
yes like yeah there you go i think that
would be great would that be a great one
i love that yeah mrs doubtfire and and i
mean mary poppins too but mary poppins
you could get like a little more like
druggy and trippy with you know because
maybe that's
part of the secret of her magic yeah the
spoonful of sugar could be like
ketamine let's see what you guys are
saying in the chat and we
uh we got some super chats too thank you
guys so much let's see what you guys are
saying in the chat i'm going to do a big
scroll through here
yes we're live so i'm seeing a lot of we
are live
guys tell us all right what do we got
here
john if you see one you let me know it's
merry stories of comedy starring jeff
bezos they you can make that a biopic
ooh tyler's i like that one the office
is a serious documentary
depression you could do it on michael
scott who
is uh just a guy who had all these
creative aspirations and dreams
and that's why he's turned into he he's
a bully that's what we could change
michael scott into being
see this is how this live stream is
gonna go we're going to be making this
up as we go along here we make elf but
where there's no
actual santa claus and he's just a guy
with a delusion about christmas
i feel like a lot of i feel like a lot
of family like you can remake like do
casper the friendly ghost but as like a
real
like you know it's like babadook yeah
exactly make it like a chilling
dark like psychological yeah horror
drama yeah that would be great
jaby's saying i want a 24 reboot keeper
sutherland to be replaced by david
hayder it's only fair
that's not a reboot in a different genre
it's just a reboot you want
that's not the subject here i want to
reboot it but where pennywise is just a
birthday clan
and he feeds off people's joy all right
okay so what do we got let's look at
some of the super chats and some people
have been super chatting
let's do it all right thank you guys so
everyone has contributed to this super
chat we also got streamlabs today i'm
gonna blow this
tf up and someone was asking when the
next umbrella academy reaction's coming
that should be tomorrow if i'm able to
get it unblocked
that's that's what my process has been
with umbrella academy
it's like anywhere from five to eight
hours of editing because
that it's usually five to six if i don't
have to re-edit it
but it's then that is usually an extra
two hours to factor in if i have to do a
couple of re-edits and or
and re-uploads or whatever so yeah
oh sorry babe it's working
oh and katie ann got me got us this
shirt oh i have mine too
we promised to wear on this live stream
oh well then i'll go put it no
it's okay john we'll do it a little bit
later all right all right the
agoraphobic
fanboy what are we doing today to make
it special um
i don't know uh let's reboot his name in
a different genre agoraphobic okay sure
it go let's see what your bit
is the let's see okay the arachnophobic
fanboy
it's a creature feature this is going to
be
great special shout outs today indiana
jones
as a shooting anime they say that right
i always read it but i never know if i'm
saying right
shooting or shouting or shoot
anime shout an anime a showering anime
where artifacts bestow power-ups and
archaeologists fight for intellectual
supremacy
at battle university oh that's a great
call you know we've been watching
jojo's bizarre adventure and by the time
we get to the second part of season one
yeah we're focused on the grandson of
jojo
i keep thinking of indiana jones
whenever i'm watching that
that show so i actually think indiana
jones as an anime
or even if you did like some one-off
anime about indiana jones
i would weirdly think it would it would
perfectly work
right there we go i actually do think it
would work
pretty well to do an indiana jones anime
i would love it plus imagine what he
could do like what power moves he would
call out as he channels his breath
through his whip
yes and what great comedic potential
you'd get out of him just like being
over it and shooting me
i would love that yeah that's a great
call robert bakara
thanks robert just remaking no no
comment but thank you robert
robert um okay how about this if you
have an actual name we'll we'll do
acronym
ones for how awesome you are r for
ripped um oh for
uh we're on a live stream john you gotta
think fast you gotta think fast go for
appreciate that robert wolf pack gaming
wolf pack gaming okay wolf pack well
wolf pack gaming thank you so much for
your super chat my dude
w you're wonderful it's such a stressful
experience going live that now that
we're lying
i feel like we're not actually i spent
all that like i was brainstorming like
things that we could do in different
genres and then i was like
it all went all that energy went into
the figure i keep thinking
that we're not live anymore i'm like at
some point we're going to be talking for
like 10 minutes and we're going to
realize we haven't been live for 10
minutes
everybody at some point today just go
listen to open mic
eagles i'm a joe star just treat
yourself to
to that song what did wolf pack gaming
say have you noticed the new
movies are only going to apple tv and
not netflix or hulu
what are your thoughts i feel like apple
tv
and hulu i mean apple tv
is in need for content that could
attract people to watch apple tv
so i think they're buying [ __ ] i feel
like they're they're probably taking
advantage of the fact that netflix has
dropped a lot of money on stuff already
and probably is like
producing now yeah and so uh i i yeah
i guess i part of me wonders if they are
quote acquiring everything or they're
just giving us an onslaught of their
acquisitions to entice us into
subscribing
um but yeah i guess that makes some
sense
thanks wolf pack gaming all right so
what did mark leach suggest today thank
you mark leach
you handsome devil you i saw you so
early in this chat
dude we can do a trade with this one how
to train your dragon
done like game of thrones and then let's
remake game of thrones season 8 in the
style of how to train your dragon oh
wait a minute you could do a how to
train your dragon like game of thrones
totally oh 100
think of how dark some of the villains
are they should do a live action
adaptation of how to train your dragon
and just really take it tonally from
game of thrones
but if you did that with game of thrones
actually you know what would be pretty
cool is a game of thrones animated you
know every every
room every reuben i'm going to say is
make it an anime
everything yeah yeah
i like it it's a good color what's with
the ice pack sassy's asking in the chat
well
the the ice packs are just a new thing
we're selling these ice packs now yeah
cool yourself down with an ice pack
people are always you know
uh wearing their t-shirts to rock their
brand
these ice packs are our brand that's
right nope
you know what i explained earlier there
was a power there's been power outages
in our area
our specific three mile radius and uh
they're asking us to not use the ac in
over a hundred degree weather
at the peak of the heat so we have ice
backs today you know we should
start merchandising items like that
instead of t-shirts and coffee mugs we
should make like ice packs or
you know a steering wheel cover or like
things that you would actually need
i guess the steering wheel covers a bad
example that's great
all right anissa anisa acronym
shout out a is for
amazing and for norwegian
the kind of guys anissa likes i for
incredible s for super
a for a and dewy
cause you're spicy like a sausage
my little pony into a horror show
yeah it lends itself to that what is my
little pony exactly
it's a show designed for
young folks that also adults get into
because it has one of those
what's the show about it it's about uh
it's about like a bunch of different
magical ponies that each i think has
their own special
power and things and they want to live
in harmony and romp around in the sky
but then stuff
threatens that harmony oh i think
damn i don't know i i assume they're
there i always associate them in my mind
with like care bears in a way where the
way like each care bear has a color and
like a special
insignia and a special power and i think
the ponies kind of have that quality
but i've never really watched it but
bronies are a very strong and
ingrained piece of our culture so uh
well i will never gonna watch my little
pony but if it was a horror show so much
deeper than you think it is
totally watching so much more serious
than you think it is
mark leach back at it again donnie darko
as a comedy buddy show about the
adventures that donnie has with his
imaginary friend
frank as a drama or wrote oh so it's
kind of like
wilfred yeah exactly that was with
elijah wood right
yeah it's pretty much what you just
described you describe the show wilfred
yeah i like it that's a great idea great
call there all right guys
let's name all right let's see here we
got
back to the future but instead wow you
are spamming
back to the future but instead of marty
time travel in 1950
oh you know he oh my god okay so he's
saying he catches the corona virus
brings it back to 1985. but
i really think uh you could do some type
of twisted version of back to the future
where marty goes back in time
and he ends up being a track like you
should start off where
what's his wife his mother's name
lorraine the rain
in the present time lorraine is like
looks totally different
super old incredibly obese and then he
time travels back to 1955
and then she looks like um a completely
different woman
kind of similar to his girlfriend and
he's very attracted to his mom and
he realizes that he is his own father
it's one of those confusing times todd's
salons
take on back to the future you want this
to get messed up i want him
to realize that that george mcfly is not
his father
marty is his own father so he has to
bang his mom
and george is a guy that he'll go back
and be part of george is a guy he
gaslit into playing the role of his
father
i really think that would work oh my god
running star-lord in the chat is saying
it um
the running man i i thought running he's
a running man as a dd
as a dating game tv show that would be
fun but i was thinking you can make
running man a comedy you could redo
the the running do you know what running
man is yeah it's like 31 but not
rob zombie style yeah but you could do
um you could do that kind of like a uh
like a
a horror comedy or something like that
yeah something that
has a much bigger sense of awareness
with its sense of humor
i imagine like an edgar right simon pegg
kind of duo for a running man kind of
film i think
would be a one that you that's a genuine
answer
yeah my whole this whole stream's gonna
consist of a lot of really sarcastic
comments and a lot of really genuine
answers today
i want to remake the fly but as like a a
slapstick comedy
oh nice we're like you know he gets all
transformed and it's not really like
scary it's more just like
kooky and inconvenient and then he has
to learn how to fit in
um let's see here okay what else you
guys saying we're looking at the chat
right now
um we're looking at the chair look into
the chat i
see uh people want you to stop spamming
if deadpool 3 happens what do you think
the plot should be uh deadpool
writing deadpool 3 and he just can't
crack the script
uh uh uh raymie spiderman one is a
horror with peter
stalking mary jane i think that i mean
there's could that could easily be a way
that turned out if peter
didn't have a great role model in his
life and uncle ben yes
and uh or aunt may too that would be
very significant if you didn't have aunt
may and he was just like this loner
and uh he became a stalker with spider
powers hey johnny that's not a bad idea
ooh judas in the chat saying john woo's
face off as a horror movie
that would be the only way you get me to
go
it's been a while since been like a
solid horror action movie
oh good call yeah and um there's been
talks about doing a face-off reboot
and i would actually watch a if if they
were saying we're making it
a psychological horror slash action
movie
yeah that would actually get me really
interested in watching uh a reboot of
face off that'll probably be the only
thing that gets me in there watching
okay shouts out to thwipster too because
sorry i see you retracted your comment
but i
totally bounced off of you for that
pitch just then of spider-man so
credit where it's due also above i see
tyler slaven halloween but as a romantic
family film where michael just wants to
find his sister and reconnect with her
and he just has a bad way of showing it
i think that'd be great plus you could
introduce at the end that michael and
her aren't actually related
so nice they could still hook up oh
claudia
is saying in the chat law order but make
it sci-fi kind of like stuff oh you
could do lawn order
special space units yeah law and order
uh
space force unit dude you know what they
should do they should remake star trek
but more like an
action movie like star wars
that's that's great that's a commentary
that's satire for you
the lobster is a horror film about what
happens to people who don't find love
isn't that what it is
what are movies that were like
unintentionally creepy
okay do you mean unintentionally creepy
in the way like that it was like
supposed to be endearing and cute but it
turned out creepy or like
something that isn't a horror movie but
that
the
yeah the first part the first one um
oh that's a great question movies like
demented yeah well i don't know about
demented but something that's like oh
wait there's like a creepy angle to this
it's like like the proposal you know i
think they should remake the proposal
um because especially in this day and
age
with cancel culture and low culture
you can really explore um just
uh the psychologically abuse if you
switch the
genders in the proposal between ryan
reynolds and sandra bullock
it would seem like a [ __ ] up movie it
would of a man
pressuring a woman to marry him who's
also the employee
it would be terrible but when you flip
the genders and you got sandra bullock
and ryan reynolds hey
it's a funny rom-com you could remake
that and explore
workplace abuse
you know what it would be it would be uh
distinct enough
to get me to uh tune in for that i would
i would be down
oh my god uh bradley in the chat saying
dora the explorer
crime drama yes oh you could do like a
30 year old explorer
still teaching you spanish but you know
applicable to dangerous
situations and maybe you know she would
have an updated
like self-defense section for when
swiper shows up
um nightmare on elm street but as a
rom-com
oh you fall in love oh freddie visits
you in your dreams you can only date
freddie in the dreams
and then what you want to do and what
you want to do is sleep
all you want to do is sleep so you can
have sex with freddie and you're just i
never wanted to sleep
until i met you friend and the whole
goal is to try to get freddie out of the
dreams
i see webster said david ayers guardians
of the galaxy which weirdly made me
think
of uh if you took bright and remade it
but as zootopia i think it would work
really well i wonder how many people
actually hear our subjects for the live
streams and the themes and then think
we're just going to take it seriously
the whole time
that really worked yeah we got some real
pitches we want to send you but but this
is i mean
you and i mean you could probably speak
to this even better than i can but this
is part of the creative process
you have to throw out a bunch of silly
ones to get to it yeah really good one
and we will hear a couple really good
ones before the night is out like the
indiana jones shonen
oh we got some uh stream labs oh
guys thank you to everyone who's
contributing our stream labs
so far john let's pull it up and uh it's
underneath in the description box but
yes we very much appreciate the super
chats but thank you
if you want to go a little bit more
direct and uh you know not give as much
to the youtube the man
uh we we love you over at streamlabs as
well kyle
kyle youtube kyle youtube all righty
where are we we're at 8 15 with tongue
punch
fart can we punch this in so more people
can see it can we
there we go tongue punch oh my god josh
this fart box professional live streams
killing the game thanks for the the
assist there
they should remake toy story but from
sid's perspective
the show he was just a boy he was
playing with toys
having fun he wasn't harming any other
kids at school
he was just having fun and then these
toys come to life and he's like i gotta
destroy these demons and where do you
think
he got the sick fascination with like
performing surgeries on toys anyway he's
probably got messed up parents
who we should really be holding
accountable for his actions dilbob
studios i'm gonna read your one thing
off
and then if you keep doing that i'm
going to have to hide you
just letting you know ghostbusters with
all the ghostbusters have schizophrenia
so schizophrenia yes yeah that's not how
you skip that
perennial these are the schizophrenia
these are the finest arthurian skits
written by the poetry
at first i did think like okay as like
as in the style of an improv troupe or
something
uh so you want ghostbusters but like
also one flew over the cuckoo's nest
or something i'm seeing here though we
are missing
okay ah there we go oh olivia does hold
the power here olivia always holds the
power
there's too much power but we got we got
small soldiers
okay let's read some of these we got to
honor the people who contributed
to our way okay but no we we've reached
the point of the live stream where we're
flowing
yeah from kyle sackett no it's tongue
punch
tongue punch fart boxer first buddy but
also kyle sackett what's up he says
obvious choice uh hey trump deontay
how's it going bud
obvious choice friends is a drama okay
perfect see this is what i'm talking
about listening last week
phoebe's dark life aside plenty of dread
to go around
ross's failed relationship puts him over
the edge i'll take it
okay become suicidal and or abuse
towards rachel
all right yeah and that's the the other
part that friends does not acknowledge
is the financial dangers ross would be
in
if he was actually going through three
[ __ ] divorces
one of them having to deal with custody
for ben
it's an expensive ass divorce
and he would be bro alimony you're a
young guy working in new york city
you are broke jesus says one step
further
um especially with the apartment you
live in monica's obesity issues cause
infertility and that causes the rift
jesus christ is chandler dead
watch this show this show is so dark
hey oh that's how the show is i love it
joey joey's dead
i love it that's so funny joey has like
you know aids or something like that
he's he's contracted
yeah let's just go ahead this is the
most bleak show you'll ever watch
angel's in america and it's gonna run
for 11 seasons
buddy i like it dionte i like it thanks
deontay kyle
sackett sack attack k for kind
y for you you know it you and l
for lovely e4 everyone loves kyle oh
sure from an outside perspective i think
it would be much easier to go from a
family sitcom to a family
uh drama genre than vice versa i just
feel the family sitcom genre
provide many options for genre swaps in
general
thoughts thank you you're welcome well
yeah i mean it's because a lot of times
the family sitcoms
are you know they're coming out with
comedic situations that are
based on not all episodes or something
but they usually stem
from something that is like real life
yeah like everybody loves raymond is one
of my favorite family sitcoms
um but you know when you think about it
you got a lot of codependency you got
a lot of rage you got a neglectful dad
a judgmental mom all these things about
everybody loves raymond
are riffing on real life things and they
make it really funny
but you could easily make uh a drama
about uh the controlling the narcissism
the do i choose between my wife or do i
choose between my family who lives
across the street
an envious brother who wants to kill rey
there's a lot of things you can do there
so yeah i think uh
undoubtedly it's easier to go from uh a
sitcom to drama than it is from drama to
comedy
i would i would be also curious to know
like what is the percentage of dramatic
family shows that does a comedic episode
to
comedic shows that randomly do a
dramatic episode because i feel like
i've heard
the comedic shows doing a dramatic
episode a lot more and i feel like that
kind of supports your point is you can
take these k
as long as we care about them it could
work you know
there is you guys are putting so many
great things
in the live stream right now i can't
wait to do a speed round about
everyone is um is contributing right now
olivia's got a good pitch in there too
eric horseman up lana pico oh wait no
lana pico i keep skipping
it's okay lana pico thank you lana
lana's real
jon take away her acronym lana lovely
a is for you give me the a's uh
ambitious uh n is for
norwegian north carolina
and a is for um
approachable you seem very kind and
approachable that's true and uh
lana says don't judge but one of my
favorite movies is sky
high which i still need to watch they
could totally flip that
and make it a darker tone story maybe
like umbrella academy meets riverdale
and really play on a kid living in the
shadow
of his superhero that's a great idea
that and at home yeah especially for
that psychological
tale at the end there yeah have you seen
sky high i just said i need to see it
john john watch sky high
hey man it worked for it worked for both
the boys and the
the snyder cut of bvs dude that is a
great
idea yeah sky high i think is a very
underrated gem
and um because i haven't seen it and it
could
it could be genuine it could be turned
into something like that of a
high school drama like river i mean
that's actually a perfect idea
and having some of that uh the comedic
sensibilities of
umbrella academy actually i think
umbrella academy is a stronger
wow no you nailed it there's nothing i
can add on to it umbrella academy meets
riverdale lana why aren't you
that's actually a perfect call yeah i
love that i would love to see that
that's a genuine
genuine appreciation for what you just
said green lit script on my desk by
monday morning
eric horstmann e4 equality is what he
fights for
r for right on
daddy
uh indubitable wow john great job
c4 cool
mother effer cool mother trucker he's
suggesting
by the way we're doing eric horseman
he's suggesting
the facts of life in the vein of the l
word
john i am praying a god because
eric horseman constantly usually is our
highest contributor
in these stream labs and super chats
yeah
and then we're always like what the [ __ ]
is eric talking
yes yes yes what is the facts of lie
i mean the facts of life is a classic uh
tv series although i
i do have to clarify it for myself right
now as to which one
it is uh but here's the log line
that is not the log line not the log
line john we are gonna figure this out
before we
john and the part i don't know that's
keeping me from breaking this down right
away because i i know what the l word is
basically and
i'm sitting here going does the facts of
life have any like lgbtq themes in it
or is it just a bunch of women or yeah
or is it just you could do golden girls
but like the
hardcore lesbians yeah like hardcore
henry do golden girls like hardcore
henry
yes oh my god hey i mean it would give
you less
whiplash all right here's what the facts
of life is about
mrs edna got it mrs edna garnett the
drummond's former housekeeper teaches to
a group of girls of a border school how
to tackle issues throughout teenage life
and later adults okay yeah that would be
perfect so they
all the girls are like repressed and
charged up and
and then you have like a lesbian drama
about that dude that is funny
that would be hilarious uh i'm down eric
horstmann
i'm down in fact oh you remember matthew
who uh had the art gallery
yeah he was on the l word no no that's
our friend we had a friend on the right
facts for everyone in
philadelphia yes i was on an episode of
sisters as a small boy
so move over thank you guys to everyone
who's been contributing
so far with the super chaps in the
stream really
really means a lot let's do a speed
round of some goodies that we got here
john yeah in fact let's scroll back up
because i saw let's see
uh olivia had one oh we said we had a
spider-man marvel movie scary with a
mission impossible twist that sounds
cool
up but it doesn't end well is the
thwipster
teen titans way to really take some of
these in
just like a quick read of them huh just
like a super quick read
you know i'm doing the chords i said
speed around but we could give like a
five to ten second take
olivia wanted to do one where it's like
batman begins but instead of like him
being batman he actually just needs an
intervention because he's uh you know
he's
crazy yeah he's insane uh
uh here let's go with this one all right
toy story but like the weeping angels
from doctor who uh
i i have actually seen that episode of
stray a long time ago and that would be
fun
instead of like them wanting to go to
sleep
when you're not around it's like they'll
only stop moving
if you're looking directly at them okay
in the chat we got 50 first dates
but like 10 cloverfield lane ooh
that would work there is a toy
that is that there we go i asked john
earlier in this stream
what is a movie that if you read through
it you can see that's kind of creepy
50 first dates yes absolutely creepy
actually that's probably my favorite
adam sandler comedy
um i'm really but every time i get to
the end of that movie where
he now has a kid with this woman and uh
he makes a videotape
i'm ruining if you haven't seen 50 first
dates this is the ending
it makes like a video tape for her every
like updates it to show where they're at
in her life
um i tear up i'm touched every single
time
but if you were to go from it on a very
realistic angle
it is one of the creepiest things you
can do
yeah and how do you possibly keep
updating that video tape to be like
you have a kid we're married just to
today woman
it would be that it would be
psychologically so hard for both of them
because you would have this guy
creating like putting time and effort
into creating this chronicle that she
will never be able to fully emotionally
connect with
oh i got one taken but
but in the style of like the pink
panther he's just like incompetent but
he failed
where he somehow fails his way through
killing everyone can see through like
he's an
irish guy pretending to be american
pretending to be a french cop comparison
okay and he just can't get oh man that
would be perfect
lana paid with her dad's paypal account
hell yeah
steal that credit card all right there's
olivia's about the batman begins with
oh that would be hilarious
fantastic 14 family drama
but you know what i really like the idea
of what josh trank was going for with
trying to find the body horror element
to fantastic four
um granted it doesn't work but if you
did a movie that was cl
you know how the boys is clearly riffing
on the justice league
yes if you did a fan a movie like
fantastic four
uh that's like like this whole thing is
clearly
riffing on fantastic four but with a
body horror angle to it
that'd be pretty neat that's how i think
you can get away with it yeah i would
love that i would love something like
that get some superhero body horror
going
yeah it's called project power watch it
on netflix today actually
i mean there is some definite body
horror of that movie and that is
pretty cool oh the goonies in the world
of chud
that actually fits right in yeah i mean
you could just it's like
that's a cinematic crossover is what
you're talking yeah yeah yeah you can
make a franchise of the goonies just
encountering things that are
subterranean
oh wait i'm looking at the wrong one all
right here we go friday the 13th but
roma style
i want to know what jason does outside
murdering yes
murdering takes up so little of the
movie the rest is the solitary character
study of a silent oaf
david ayers guardian of the galaxy oh my
god that's great
james gunn takes over suicide squad
david takes over guardians
i would love it because yeah it would be
like super gritty and they would all be
like hispanic for some reason and yeah
perfect
dodgeball is an anime that could work i
just saw dodgeball again it was not bad
all right it's directed by the same guy
who did skyscraper
ross and therma is my moon is still in
the chat
where i don't know i'm not sure comment
let us know
teenage mutant ninja turtles reboot but
like
new mutants where they're like
you could do teenage mutant ninja
turtles but make it
if you really commit to it like they're
imprisoned in a lab where they were
created
no you just do the michael let's just do
the michael bay one
no but it's better if you did teenage
you could do a version of teenage i
think they tried
with the animated one tmnt they tried
doing uh like
let's really make this a ninja movie to
a certain extent
and uh i think i think uh you could do
that with teenage mutant ninja turtles
like it's teenage mutant ninja turtles
means ghost of tashima
yeah which is ninja turtles three
ghosts of the ghost of the pizza
all right what do we got here um
toy soldiers with samuel jackson tom
hanks and de niro what does that even
mean
is toy soldiers a movie or is it small
soldier
the first one i saw a joker they oh by
the way guys i gotta shout out this
shirt really quick i want to make sure i
didn't properly shout out earlier
vaginas aren't that bad
apparently they're not this is what
people are saying on discord anissa said
it
and then katie ann made it for us so
thank you katie yeah thank you i'll grab
mine at some point it's here i have it
and vaginas are awful vaginas are except
for my girlfriend
overrated she's got the best one she's
got the only good one
she's got the old one every other
offense to all the women in the chat
right now but only my girlfriend's
vagina all your others
you should be ashamed of yourself
remake this live stream is an offensive
horror movie they should do
um what's the matthew mcconaughey all
right all right one
uh oh they like dazed and confused yeah
yeah
dude jason confused but a psychological
horror film
about how [ __ ] up matthew mcconaughey
is not a predator
he's grooming high school girls that it
ends with him in behind
in the in the police car in the back and
he's just looking out as the students
are watching him
and the credits will roll over that [ __ ]
and he's like
all right all right all right i'm going
to jail yeah
the movie ends with him just repeating i
keep getting older they stay the same
and he just had to go to his prison cell
in the post credit scenes that he has
all right all right he gets out of
prison and he just heads to the next
high school as an old old man from uh
what's uh
his true detective yeah nasty
oh let's see here small wonder
what is small wonder jean jeter let us
know
the non-vagina monologues the penis
monologue
psych has a 1950 cop thriller you know
what i would i really want to see a
batman movie but in the uh 1940s i would
love that
1940s 1950s era i think that would be
like
not during world war ii but either right
before or right after world war ii what
is thrill killer
although if you're doing it during the
great depression it could work didn't
thrill killer
that that like there's there's at least
one book that you had me read ages ago
that
has like the joker's like i said don't
leave this room until you read this card
but yeah like the joker's like a female
crime boss or something and it's like in
the
the 40s or the 5th oh i wrote that
that's my idea well i loved that book
right
i mean you should you should write more
are you a writer you should write
justice league but a political drama
where america has to vote for the leader
and members have to get paid
who gets to is superman is batman really
fit to lead the justice league
uh let's see here
let's let's purge remake what would you
remake the purge as
a sports movie they should remake the
purge but with a bunch of
really shy insecure people who just
they should remake the purge but during
coronavirus so no one wants to get
pandemic purge yeah no one wants to get
it worst
purge numbers we've ever seen six feet
apart man if you're gonna kill me stay
six feet apart the only murder this week
was over masks and gloves
they'll be good we should call plum
houses we got their new idea
and they can make it in like 20 minutes
oh
god that's hello that's hilarious
it's a wolverine tv series but it's just
oh we got some more super chats i keep
missing these supers
do your thing you got this i got this we
got this
together all right so we're going to
open this
they should remake the shadow yeah it's
about time like batman begin style
you know make it all like like gritty
and psychological and like more down to
earth and realistic
like what if the shadow really existed
in our world today
because that's exactly what batman
begins did it's 100
realistic yeah that's the key is just
making [ __ ]
real uh we got niraj uh who
asked a while ago if the super chats
were working
oh here we go n for no way you're
ever leaving our lives e for
everybody loves niraj e4
excelente r for
range the man has a lot of ranges
moderate great actor great
a for acting is great with mirage and
j for juicy murder she wrote thank you
for the super chat murder she wrote she
is a
sweet old lady who used to be a serial
killer
the novel she writes are accounts of her
kills
set in the 40s or 50s that's great it's
like a bit of a
basic instinct angle if sharon stone
continued being an author no that's
that's basic instinct but he just did
but with an old lady
that is it but she's still seducing and
murdering people even as an old lady you
got reference in the pitch
this made me think of what if you remade
like herald and mod but as like a really
disturbing
like anti-christ style like relationship
ah that's great yeah it would be really
people would love it
they should remake space jam from the
point of view of his son
where's our dad dad never [ __ ] cares
he just disappeared and he's playing
baseball anissa back at it thanks anisa
shawshank redemption into a romantic
comedy i've never seen shawshank
redemption so
it's about two guys in prison it's i
love you philip yeah
you beat me to it that's exactly it so
wish granted
which i've had to avoid spoilers on that
movie because it's it's been on lately
uh in in the in the place where i live
mark leach
m bleach m is for mack daddy
a for assalius r
for rub it in
c4 cool as a cat oh yeah
jurassic park as a tiger king like
documentary
oh jurassic park that is a great call i
love it that could work
i love it that could work yeah you'd
have jeff goldblum as the one guy as
like uh yeah the armless person
when [ __ ] gets out of hand you could
totally see dr hammond looking to the
camera and saying
i'm never gonna financially recover from
this
oh yes yes yes and then you could get
like the marketing people who were like
yeah you seem crazy to me but it was a
job you know
wanted me to help with this campaign to
get more customers in the park oh that
dinosaur has a baby coming out get the
shot get the shot at the dinosaur heaven
a bunch of dead fish have been just
washing up on the shore and that's what
we feed the dinosaurs
and sometimes we feed them the guests
too oh wow that would be
great yeah that would be more fun as
jurassic world as a tiger king like
documentary that would be the because
those people are because
that's where it's already open yeah
exactly exactly it's like yeah this has
been profiting for a while
there are guests on hand who you could
watch somebody have to cover in front of
that is great
yes it'll ever happen but it's great yes
and oh follow-up chase gardner
another another jurassic park one chase
all right c is for
uh crunk h is for
heavenly a is for
a i already said ambitious
and i'm saying it again s is for super
special
e is for eloquent he says jurassic park
where all the dinosaurs are actually
transformers
that would never work more than jurassic
park
like if they were all transformers they
would just destroy whatever cage they're
in and get out can you imagine that
breakout movie jurassic park's run time
will be trimmed at least
an hour and a half they don't get
anywhere near opening the park
it's like the first one they turn on
it's all over
i like it though still have a lot of
carnage i like it chase mm-hmm
bradley bledsoe go check out bradley
love star
on on spotify go check out his album
it's out
covers of some great 80s classic jams
bradley is saying uh well wait hold on
really quick
b for bitchin oh r for
uh rub a dub dub when bradley's in the
tub a
for always with me
d for give me that d bradley
l for lick my d bradley
e for excellent d bradley y
for yes to that d bradley he says how's
it going dudes
i would love to see yeah i mean oh [ __ ]
the mask
i mean yeah okay he's how's it going
dudes
how'd it go dudes i would love to see
the mask rebooted into a dark comedy
drama
like the original comic or fantastic
four with the actual body horror
well i already did the whole fantastic
fourth thing
but the mask is exceptionally darker in
its comic
as a matter of fact i think if you
rebooted the mask i don't think you can
get away with it in
in a movie but if you wanted to do like
a tv show
like a 10 episode one for i don't know
netflix or something
and you wanted to honor the original
comic a lot more
uh i think doing a netflix 10-episode
show of the mask would be great
and get this get this cast jamie kennedy
that's better than mine but i was gonna
say cast jim carrey but today jim carrey
because he's you know a lot darker now
very existential stuff very existential
jamie
dominic zeferi oh my god we're gonna
we're gonna do we're gonna do domin
domin d for delicious
o for omg domini
m for my my my i for
i love you and for no way it's dominic
all right we got to we did we did we're
dominant
cat in the hat but horror and he turns
the children into thing one
and thing two didn't they do a cat in
the hat but a horror trip oh they did a
cat in the habit with pennywise
it but with the cat in the hat yeah
something like that yeah one of those
one of those meme mashems that was funny
yeah oh canon the hat is definitely one
that's actually really scary
yeah it's scary if you shot it in a way
that felt very grounded
and just it all took place at night
yeah if you shot with a lot of wide
lenses yeah all took place at night and
he's like in the shadows and he moves
more like a real cat does
i mean that's like i think an example of
a movie that isn't
a scary movie but yeah kind of creepy
they should uh reboot hamilton but
without any of the rap
yeah just his dialogue just dialogue
uh let's see here denise is back anissa
back at it
a disney movie with both parents that
don't
die well what would the character have
to grow for well then it's not
a real disney movie then anissa god it's
like taking michael myers at a halloween
what do you have then
season of the witch an underrated film
vaginas aren't that bad they're not
anissa's back at it here a disney movie
where a family member doesn't die
okay okay let's see okay well as much
gotta be one
as i i appreciate the super chats but
these are not real disney movies but
there's got to be at least one disney
movie where a family member doesn't die
there has to be does anybody die in in
well arthur is like an orphan toy story
one no one dies
nobody died in toy story they just it's
a rescue mission
yeah they're trying to well but maybe
andy's dad died
passion of the christ uh no no someone
dies at the end
but it comes back so it doesn't count
disney's passion of the christ disney's
passion of the christ
yeah uh well disney should make a jesus
movie that would be great
that would be terrific and especially
i saw somebody in the in the chat uh
pitched a a
little mermaid remake but in the style
of the actual hans christian anderson
source material that's much darker so
you could you could do that with uh
what we were just talking about step
brothers
as a psychological thriller thanks
bradley blitzeau
yeah about two two adults who need
serious counseling oh that could work
that could work yeah
that sounds realistic everyone in that
movie is toxic enough that if you just
turned down the absurdity it would it
would it would work what was that there
was a
there's a move paul rudd i think you had
the word idiot in the title
our idiot brother already a brother
which was ended up being a little bit
more nuanced than people
expected you could kind of do that with
step brothers but they are trying to
kill each other at the end
you can make it like funny games oh
yeah and then they kidnap those kids at
the end and torture
instead of making them eat the white dog
poop
mark leech is back mark leach ninja
turtles but as a cronenberg horror
dude that's what i'm talking about you
get like a [ __ ] up splinter in there
yeah yeah looking like the rat from the
witches like when the kid transforms and
it's like a puppet yeah it's all gross
and slimy and pointy looking and yeah
you could have oh my god and they like
kidnap april o'neil
yeah oh dude and she's like [ __ ] yeah i
should be horrified
see it works yeah jimmy freckles in the
chat
thanks jimmy j for
jovial i for
impotent not he is
m for mack daddy again
m for [ __ ] jimmy
you why for yeah jimmy
joker flew over the cuckoo's nest
you know if that would actually be the
logical thing
i call hollywood called todd phillips
out of all the sequel ideas i've heard
and i've even come up with one that i
liked for a joke or two
that actually sounds like the most
natural version
of a joker sequel you can do
you can get harleen quinzel in there
yeah and you can
just have her be a psychiatrist yeah and
then you can have him
feeding all sorts of ideas to the other
inmates because he would be like the
sort of like different
guy in the room and then cause some kind
of stir that gets all the
you know breaking out not a bad call
yeah that's a great call
jimmy freckles you did it jimmy you're
good you did it jimmy
you did it jay and then uh let's go
let's read some of this soup okay we'll
go to
they i see we got a bunch in stream labs
here we're gonna check those out in a
bit but let's do a speed round of the
comments
comment speed round whatever you guys
said so
far here um let's see chat's not loading
joker directed by martin scorsese i mean
we kind of already got that
oh i'm at the bottom already my bad no
i'm not all right
poppins versus mcphee would
i would just be on board even though
that's not like a reboot but yeah i mean
i guess it is it's like a dual reboot as
a fighting movie
so i like it oh someone's calling out
whap in the chat i just that's not a
reboot but i feel like there's been so
many that have come in
john wick versus the equalizer where
were you guys where were you on
crossover week
i love the shirt anisa thank you anisa i
love this shirt too anisa
thank you niece is the best man
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay i see
i see her if you're gonna change you
better change in front of the camera i'm
just gonna put the shirt on over this
drawer oh my god he's too embarrassed
man up take your shirt off in a live
stream yeah
john take your shirt off i'll do
anything for a hashtag i tell you what
but i promise you now i'm not going to
because my girlfriend forbids it
i have i have an excuse i made up there
you go oh a little tease right there
a little tease that right it's live john
we lost all our viewers right when you
took your shirt off
everyone just completely stopped
watching all of a sudden
there we go all right what did i miss
nothing i was i pretended like i was
looking at the live stream chat but
really i was looking at you in the
in heart i was looking at you on the
screen oh good venom is a drama
body rot what's up dog it's good to see
you venom as a
drama with a film-like mask
you mean mask like uh i mean you should
reboot venom as a [ __ ] like horror
movie that too you can make venom an
actual horror movie will work too yeah
make it a combination mask and that you
know i guess share to still be
i love iron man but ace ventura
holy testicle tuesday oh john wick in a
romantic comedy
isn't that the one he made with uh
winona ryder that's not john wick
he looks like john wick he's got the
same hair and beer
it could be one of those these should
just make john wick 5 should be a
romantic comedy where he meets a new
woman he falls in love with her
but he keeps having to kill guys in
secret
i have a date in an hour and he just
keeps having to kill people to get to
that date
yeah and he shows up to every date
sweaty and cuddled yeah
i like it and he'll be at the restaurant
and i'll see that he has to like [ __ ]
uh shoot someone across yeah yeah the
whole i really want this
relationship to work out all the time
he's eating dinner he's secretly killing
just trying to have a nice time but like
no one will leave him alone gets into a
cool bathroom fight
yeah exactly comes back for dessert
it'll be great
oh i like it i like it i like it friday
the 13th
as a musical i i still want to make a
quiet place the musical just because of
the irony factor
that's about as good as that idea
deserved
stranger things but it's an animated
series and set in the 60s is not a bad
idea
whatsoever shouts out to no name too
remake of rob zombies halloween kid mike
was fun to watch what do you reject
think his original idea was to have it
be like
kid mike the whole movie and then end it
with him breaking out of the asylum and
i kind of want to see that movie so i'm
with you
shrek but thanos i would watch that
reboot
let's see here what are we doing shrek
but with shrek even
better real rejects was remade in a
different genre from the homophobic
totally offensive ryan
i wasn't homophobic if anything i was
way pro homosexuality
hey yeah i added every straight to the
point every straight for every review i
did was i would totally suck this guy
yeah there's a lot of dick sucking going
on with ryan right
genre to the open minded greg alba genre
yeah see i i i heard there was a me too
movement coming a year from when i
decided to stop doing
it right it's like insider training i
better [ __ ] change
who i am now i better get ahead of this
whole being a good person
happens i better stop assaulting people
geez
gosh oh boy the cable guy is a
tear-jerking character drama
guys there are people pitching mrs
doubtfire you're clearly late to the
stream we had a great mrs doubtfire idea
that sounds similar to a lot of people
so we're obviously not the only ones who
thought of that
yeah i mean you know you watch it again
as an adult and it kind of comes through
uh mr bean care bears as a werner herzog
documentary
the bears each with their own quality to
bring to mankind
human beings devoid of care who do you
need
i'm just going to keep heart talking
until you find somebody pee-wee in the
style of nightcrawler
[Laughter]
instead of uh his buddy character you
would just have like
the like the talking seat of his car
yeah and things like that
all right let's see here
[Music]
i i respect you too anisa mad max bit oh
it's just you all right cool
alfred from batman but he's kingsman i
like it
suicide squad but it's a good movie oh
bill and ted is a stoner movie all right
okay guys i see uh we got some uh oh wow
we we have
some stream labs here that we definitely
got to cover
some of you guys have been so kind wayne
bro
no bruce bain do i have it here john
there it is at the very top roos brain
thank you bruce bane thank you
that is that is a a [ __ ] on the
eyeballs
hi uh i just woke up in an unfamiliar
room
chained to bed that feels like a toppled
fridge a big tv screen
out of my reach is showing cats on loop
at a deafening volume
and with awful brightness and settings
could someone help me please
i'm hungry no
no no no i mean no you are trapped there
forever and
every week i expect you to show up in
our stream labs
and give us an update per stream lab
contribution
this is a test this is an elaborate
escape room and uh if you haven't
figured out what katz is trying to tell
you
of course you haven't gotten out we set
this up for you roose pay close
your attention pay close attention
caltor tourx
altour tourx man
that is that's like if turok started
doing accounting
remake the real rejects into a crime
drama
two guys watch crime scene videos
where they find missed clues and now
they need to solve the case
keep up the guys and keep up
the guys keep up the guys keep those
guys up
and stay cool could even have an episode
where the air is out hey that would be
uh that would that would suck to have to
deduce crimes
with no air conditioning i would totally
be a great
you know i couldn't be a cop i would
plan evidence
i know for a fact i planned just just in
case i don't want to like look bad so
i'm just like
i had a good reason there's evidence
yeah
case closed you don't want to see the
real rejects remade into a crime drama
because it'll be us learning about the
law it's going like how does this work
the whole time
what what how do i fire this thing who
do i
do like olivia could you come in here
when do i get to shoot somebody
oh that's we don't do that damn
um let's see thank you kaltur thank you
so much
scrap looking forward to more remake the
real rejects
eventually it's gonna be funny and then
i'm gonna be like i guess they just
don't like the way the real rejects are
then you're gonna get a bunch of videos
in a whole bunch of different styles
any godz uh scrapzilla thanks scrapzilla
what a great name any godzilla movie by
the way
of wreck-it ralph godzilla doesn't want
to be the bad guy
anymore and decides to leave japan
without the king of the oh you could do
this like an anime that's great
without the king of the monsters the
japanese government
um the sanji forced to get godzilla back
in order to stop an impending alien
invasion
but he doesn't want to kill anymore he
just wants to be a good guy
he just wants to hang out and befriends
like a little boy yeah he's like i want
to be friends with a little boy
i just wanna yeah be friends with this
little boy and like garden in a like a
giant national park somewhere
then we remake that one with a little
boy as a creepy psychological thriller
yeah like what would happen if a monster
raised you remakeception
oh yeah yeah yeah remake and also make
it a sequel but that doesn't matter in
the genre
hey where's bruce back
okay i didn't bother to read what the
topic was
so my apologies for that senseless
streamlab earlier here's an actual
attempt
how about the neverending story as a
horror which for kids it almost was
stay classy guys you know i mean it
freaked me out
it still freaks me out i don't think
i've actually seen it in one sitting
i'm pretty sure i've just seen like
glimpses and images of it and that
[ __ ]
was that a dragon or a dog oh oh yeah
it's like a big
stretchy dog thing yeah yeah that thing
freaks me the [ __ ] out
see yeah i wouldn't [ __ ] with that
stretchy dog man
oh [ __ ] with that stretch well the thing
is
both both labyrinth and neverending
story or were movies i saw as a kid that
are just these these like
echoes of memory in my mind where like i
have these flashes and glimpses and i
know the iconography but i feel like
i ought to go back and like really
re-watch them now and i feel like doing
that will be a creepy experience that's
very true
so uh yeah i think it you get guillermo
del toro to remake it horror style let's
do it
roose it works for me dude bruce bane
eric eric back at it
psycho but as a comedy like porkies
please tell me you know porkys i've seen
porky that's the comedy with sean penn
definitely what's next that's fast i was
originally
porky's is another uh you know comedy
with champa yeah
sex teen sex comedy or like revenge of
the nerds or things like that oh i
haven't seen it
uh yeah but you can make psycho but as a
comedy
yeah it's like you did it all from
normal if you did all from like norman
bates's perspective you could get away
with it
and he's like about to graduate high
school he's like he's about to finish
senior year he's helping his mom
out but he's also his mom but then
there's guys we gotta throw a party at
bates motel yeah
yeah it's just about him getting overrun
with guests who are all sexy
in a different way and like he has to
tend to them but he also wants to spy on
the chicks because he's like repressed
and stuff and then
yeah it's perfect what do you guys think
about more yellow lighting in here
more and more yellow look how blown out
we are
balance uh nick nick a doug
nicka doug is here oh i made it so much
brighter
oh no no wait we go up yeah no no we got
it yeah that's a little better
we're still super yellow if we had the
white lights on oh my god we'd be
[ __ ] sweating our balls off right
testicles but thanks eric horseman
doug what a great name yeah is that your
real name
nick doug yeah nick a
doug does that mean something not to me
spend the rest of the livestream figure
this
you just out to combine nick and doug
and you couldn't think of a better way
than just putting an a in between
thanks bud nick doug is a great name
sharkboy and lava girl
turned into dark fantasy r rated movie
directed by guillermo del toro oh you
could have like the fantastical elements
and you could really make sharkboy and
lava girl there's like these crazy
creepy designs
yeah totally totally and it's about this
brother and sister and they fall in love
with each other
and it's like wrong but
yeah he made incest all right
he made it beautiful okay he made it
beautiful right it's art
it's too consensual people in love all
right with the context the movie and
they're different species too so like
kind you know he's she's shark and he's
he's lava you know like or
vice versa whatever i'm for it
i would also this club is for him
i feel like i would also be down for
zack snyder's sharkboy and lava girl
because you know i want to see that get
get bleak that'd be great yeah eric's
back
eric horseman edward scissorhands but as
a porn
edward penis hands but they're all like
actual penises right not like dildos
like these guys they should all be like
different sizes
they shouldn't be erect penises everyone
i think when you hear edward penis hands
you think of like
just erecting yeah that sounds more
convenient they shouldn't be erect did
you just be like
like keep flopping everywhere
yeah the thing about his dick fingers is
they shouldn't all be erected but they
should all just have you know all the
necessary nerve endings so that they get
erect or faceted independently of one
another
because think of how annoying that would
be but when he gets around winona ryder
then they all get arrested
get erected
is going in so many directions of how
that would have to see
you guys get it kyle's sack it's back
oh it's kyle sackett uh
second teenage mutant ninja turtles live
action series in the style of the boys
or john wick
where the turtles are [ __ ] up it could
work as the boys
if you if you made like if you had this
sense of humor actually seth rogen is
redoing he's doing he's producing the
new uh ninja turtles
um but if you did an r-rated ninja
turtles but
for like you know their reaction to like
some if you have like violence where
they're [ __ ] up people
and or you know they're the teenage
mutant ninja turtles teenagers are
swearing all the time and making dumb
dick jokes
like two 30 year old men doing a live
stream
um yeah you could do teenage mutant
ninja turtles but in the more i would
see it more akin to the style of the
boys
where you have that kind of stuff yeah i
think actually
if seth rogen's able to do it r-rated
ninja turtles i feel like it could
actually work
oh totally if he and evan goldberg are
behind it yeah
and like they're able to make it r-rated
i really think they could pull it off
yeah you know they would have the banter
the action and yeah yeah oh that would
be pr they would they would be perfect
yeah okay t what's up katie
katie anne the girl who gave me the
vaginas
aren't that bad shirt and gave john the
same vaginas aren't that bad shirt
because they're not guys they're not
that bad
they're not that bad this is actually a
charity vaginas aren't that bad
donate to your local vagina you donate
and we send money to many vaginas across
the state of california in need of help
this is going well i don't know what
that means this is this is what our
mission statement will be for the
impending for the charity we set up
stephen king's misery exploring kathy
bates character origin
history of trauma and being attacked by
ed harris's character
of the writer therefore justifying her
imprisonment
and torture of him and gaining does she
mean
james khan she means james con right i
was like unless we're recasting who did
ed harris play in this
airport justifying her imprisonment and
torture
of him and gaining empathy from the
audience
despite her craziness oh actually
you know out of all nurse ratchet
they're doing the the ryan murphy's
producing that re uh the origin of nurse
ratchet
um but actually kathy bates's character
could probably be more interesting well
because
it would be a more personal study it
seems like it would be like you would
dive deeply into
her you would probably have to still
dive somewhat into him but you could
really contain that whereas
ratchet you have you're geared up for
ensemble you know and
like her escaping into the books all the
time yeah and you cast like a
super super popular actor to play the
james
who would be the new the the younger
version of the kathy bates and misery
oh let's see let's see beanie feldspar
amber heard
for free larson i mean kathy bates is a
good enough character actress that she
could probably just
get young she could probably just do it
get younger for the role i like your
idea katie i like it thank you
yeah it's that time guys where we speed
around through your weird pics that you
have in the chat
it's that time again where where'd the
live stream where'd the proper one go
john oh it's there it is i found it john
don't worry don't yell at
her don't yell at me you guys can't see
this hey it's okay don't worry about it
you know we can do can we do
that where'd it go oh where'd it go
john which one where's my life
john what are you trying to do with my
life what are you trying to find
help me out with my life oh there we go
then we can see what we're scrolling
through we have to cook oh good thinking
yeah oh my god look at that you invited
all my friends
good thinking vaginas oh wait no we got
all these block comments
there's a reason why they're blocked
let's
we're on the screen i was like oh whoa
whoa we can't have that i want to go
through a stroll in our notes
my bad okay oh goodness this is why we
need a moderate nah
this doesn't work well if we have a
moderator no game of thrones spin-off
but hardcore and restaurant
i mean anything with an interesting
world would work pretty well as
as at least like i would watch that as a
hardcore henry you know at least once
so i'm i'm with you despite how uh
goofy that came across just now anisa
and olivia
mashup oh where we like splice them
together as human beings or where
they're like buddies together
i support both charlie's angels as a
woman in prison film so
charlie's angels meets orange is the new
black yeah
and and also with like even more
exploitation yeah
i like that idea i think it would be
cool
all right let's see here the hangover
as a serious lost person drama
but they still find him in the same
place they they do
in the movie in the original movie i
think that would be great oh my god
if you did the hangover 2 properly in in
thailand you made it just like a
terrifying
film bunch of americans in a foreign
full of crime
like a totally racially insensitive
movie yeah make it like
last blood but funny do it
i love it oh goodness king kong me it's
a plan of the ape style movie so it's
like playing
the apes where everyone's giant i like
it
all the humans like like uh charlton
heston's a tiny guy oh star-lord i love
your comment
cancelled as a documentary but then gets
cancelled by the cancel culture
oh for being for depicting too much
offensive stuff and then they'll be like
but we're just reporting on it and
they're like i don't care
uh let's see here hey don't be
flabbergasted by the penises all right
the real rejects support incest hashtag
cancel oh
no i don't support all incest just when
guillermo del toro does it
specific circumstances just like when he
you know you i wouldn't support [ __ ]
a fish man
does it i'm like yeah he's still you're
a little [ __ ] let him do it
you know i louie case performing comedy
in ohio
right now yeah i was surprised to see
him i was surprised to see that and i
was surprised to see who
some of the people who were with him on
stage let's see here
knight rider in the style of dexter i
like that alien as a silent movie oh
that would be cool i like it i want it i
i want it with like
informational titles you know make a
great alien remake would be nicholas
when in ruffin
yeah make a perfect one yes
there'll be a whole like 10 minutes of
ripley and the xenomorph just staring at
each other
and then another five minutes of her
staring into the little mouth
as it slowly comes out
john your warner hersog is appreciated
oh hell yeah
i gotta get better at it but i i
appreciate that that's gonna fuel my
fire
i do wear my shirt in the pool i did i
used to when you're younger
john would always remember i would hold
it in the pool i was so self-conscious
about my body
and i still am but to a lesser degree
now he flaunts it around like a [ __ ]
that's right free the nipple
oh [ __ ] uh and my girlfriend i argued
about this forever with the sopranos
because everyone there says who are who
are who or
who or whoever how they say
horror in it you haven't seen the
surprise you know what i'm going for
who are who were they they have a very
specific way of saying it not [ __ ]
this is the part of the livestream where
greg tries to say horror like the cast
on the surprise yeah with that where are
they set in like new york or staten
island new jersey new jersey okay yeah
it says so it's like the word horrible
with that new jersey it's not horror
you're doing like al pacino
all right
well yeah i can see how i don't know i'm
sorry guys
i'm gonna have to watch sopranos for
this alone
who are how the [ __ ] did they say the
horde and the surprise [ __ ]
reboot it's ruined
oh goodness gracious cool whip
everything tastes better with cool whip
stop saying what what way
three amigos as a serious western never
be ashamed of your body john
always never be ashamed of my body
dude uh i i totally support you posting
the clip of us repeating the word [ __ ]
out of context
definitely there's not like a woman in
the room and we haven't named anyone
justice league but in the style of the
disaster artist from snyder's point of
view
that i think would be very fun who would
play zack snyder
justin chatwin all right let's also play
goku jackie says always i can set us up
for the super chits
oh we're gonna do a little bit of a
reload guys i'm gonna have to take a
[ __ ] really quick for the next 15
minutes
really quick i see a lot of people leave
live streams to go peep
not my style no i only leave that [ __ ]
we do this astronaut style we're we got
toilets in the chair
okay we got we literally left the
livestream for like 20 minutes
took a giant [ __ ] oh
buddy buddy buddy okay okay so the last
one jimmy freckles with joker flew over
the cuckoo's nest so let's kill the
title and bring this back out okay we
got who's next
anissa's next whap macaroni and
pot just as a heads up this is a 15 to
20 minute warning um because i still got
to edit umbrella academy to get it up
tomorrow and those take like five to six
hours to edit like i said earlier
and um i gotta make sure it's not
blocked so that's why
that we're gonna try to wrap this up
around seven ten we'll do
we're gonna do our best right now and i
know we started late so i feel bad about
that but we're originally gonna want to
end by seven
so ten more minutes to make up for this
30 minutes
that weird troubleshooting scenario all
right who do we got
the mayor no uh uh i mean iniesta
nissa with web in case you guys don't
know means wet ass [ __ ] oh yeah
definitely wet ass [ __ ] if you guys
want to see a reading of
john and i breaking down the lyrics of
that song go check out our patreon
really i might just take that part where
we're reading the lyrics
and uh yeah yeah shrek okay
uh whop in a macaroni pot they should
they should
remake that music video
but with but with kylie jenner in every
room
kylie jenner if you really yeah yeah
yeah i think that's what the public
wanted they were like
not enough of this face that would be so
funny
uh uh who we got next the mayor
shrek mayor anthony garcia's in the chat
hey
he's like sorry for the power outages in
your area sorry guys
shrek into a porno it's already
a porno shrek into a portrait you
haven't got i don't know if you want to
correct then you're not aware why would
you want to watch
that well yeah
i mean you know don't get it yeah
donkey yeah why clap don't get
in a single few words if i went to his
[ __ ] donkey
yeah fiona well he would have to [ __ ]
donkey for the first three quarters of
the porn parody until he and fiona
clinched their love affair and then
he has a three-way with her and farquaad
where farquaad gets cooked there you go
we just we just pitched your
uh shrek porno movie
yes romero sanchez without even such
a peep in the notes thank you so much
for your generosity romero r
for rick ridiculous
a4 absolutely
oh yeah em something about jackie chan
mel gibson alex romero
uh uh uh i for indominable
and uh r for ravioli
uh yeah just just left us a moment of
zen so thank you for that
sylvester sylvester fryson jr
we got a double whammy here from
sylvester thank you sylvester
oh buddy the avengers but
in the style of the office there's
already a show that
i pitched that this should be a disney
plush show yeah
who is thor's roommate
that daryl sketch there should be a
daryl show on disney plus a 23
20 23 minutes 23 minute like a half hour
comedy on on
on disney plus and every week there's a
new guest star and he like works at like
avengers headquarters or something yeah
every and they send him on missions like
you got to go to wakanda
yeah how funny would that be yeah and
he's got to do like you know
pa stuff like i've been wanting them to
kind of do a version of that
yeah uh of like that daryl thing but for
um the dc verse dc world of a guy who
works at arkham asylum
he's just like a janitor he's just like
a dude who works at arkham he's just
filing [ __ ] and having to deal with all
this crazy nonsense every day
science of the lambs is a romantic
comedy i've seen that trailer that was
great yeah also deontay just adding to
the uh the mayor's shrek porto uh donkey
did [ __ ] a dragon so yeah it would be
plausible
uh sylvester goes on to say a horror
reality show featuring jason voorhees
michael myers freddy krueger candy man
chucky scream and jigsaw like
like i suppose i haven't done that yet
yeah i mean there's there are like
you know like a sketch is there a sketch
i feel like there is
yeah i've definitely seen people do like
artistic renderings of them all playing
cards
yeah but uh yeah as like an actual show
i would uh i would be curious to see how
you could make it in a way that actually
would last you know
um uh nope the jigsaw one uh working
with jigsaw living with jigsaw
i think that's that would be a great
streaming service show yes
if and if you just get them at 10
minutes i think that would be great too
yeah
yeah exactly and then have you know like
weird actual morale
weird little morality tales mds omega
m for macho d
for dragon dick
the chronicles of narnia as a horror
i mean it definitely would lend itself
to that as a as like a
youth it uh fantasy it definitely has
like stuff that's kind of scary for kids
just be the kids freaking out yeah it's
just hockey lion
oh god kill it it's just them freaking
out and destroying all of narnia
and never really learning about like the
witch and everything
she corrupts them they die it's bleak
be good thanks mds omega and nisa
oh well thank you this is for this is
for john taking off
your shirt you've got tip for taking
your shirt off the second time i've been
paid in my life as a stripper i've been
paid to put my shirt back on
oh what does that mean it's all right
it's all right i've
i've never been able to do that so
you're special
hillary b's in the chat hillary b
h for hell yeah i for
i want some l for
lick yourself e for
everywhere r for row
your way to fortune yay
a y for uh
youthful don't have any just wanted to
drop in and say
love you guys and keep up the work oh
thank you
waiting patiently for some requests i
sent in a while back lol
john react to some of the music videos
all right all right all right just
record them on your phone at your home
react to them john
i will get on it hillary's mad at you
all right all right she's saying you
want to drop in and send some love
that's [ __ ] she's mad hillary's
she sends me messages on patreon being
like man [ __ ] that humphrey
and i'm like hillary please i feel the
same way yeah
i'm sure a lot of people do it's a
common sentiment in my life
oh jon it's okay don't kill hillary
i'm not just take the heat you know what
i'm gonna take this on the chin hillary
and i'm gonna
react to so many music videos it's gonna
you're gonna be so tired of music videos
it's gonna be great haunting of hill
house but as a comedy
the addams family style yeah
i i guess you do the haunting of hill
house as a comedy
um it should work
i guess it could you would have to maybe
trade trauma for like more
trivial conflicts that manifest
themselves as ghosts
bless you i guess you could do haunting
of hill houses
i i could see it being like if you if
you like it would be adam's family-ish
and tone and then if you made it like
the office or something where it's like
you know here we're documenting us
fixing up this house
you know and and do it that way who can
make it be work
i love how eric horseman hops between
here and stream labs
he's like me when it's like you don't
need to
we appreciate it though buddy thank you
i appreciate you looking out for both
streams
yeah um let's see alan ramsey
alan a4 adams allen apple
l for love ya a
for [ __ ] he is not
n for nibble
on your ear all right i would like to
tick-tock but not the 2016
thriller it's about the app wait there's
a 2016 thriller named tick tock
uh there might be c's in the title but
but uh yeah i guess
maybe let's look it up let's go to the
imdb everyone's favorite part where we
google stuff
oh yeah where we take time out tick tock
spell right movie i think so i think so
i don't know though let's see it's a
2000 film
2000 tick tock nope got it
oh a wealthy man becomes suspicious of
his younger wife and hires a
private detective in time to thwart her
plans uh race against a clocker
kill oh it's a kevin tenney movie okay
tick tock but
oh no it's 2016. all right well dang
i'm so committed i'm going to watch it
tonight oh it is smelled like the app
dang
oh it's a it's a chinese film oh good
so we got to remake this but on
tick-tock
it's a police thriller who's the crime
mission he's saying tick-tock but not
the 2019-16 thriller it's about the app
i totally got it wrong we there was no
reason to find out what this tick tock
2016 movie is
and here we have ourselves a bit there
is no reason to find
this this thing the whole thing was him
going
don't get it confused with the 2016. i
just wanted to know what i was doing
i wanted a point of reference for
non-confusion hunting down this movie
so that everyone can go check it out
but now i know what it is and it's cool
to know more stuff alan you got it
thanks alan
tick tock but about the app we we
[Music]
d is for dimples i'm sure you got some
cute what is this sticker
it's a stickier it's um
what is this sticker i can't tell if it
says thanks
thanks for being you and it's a little
like pear-shaped person with a little
headband on looking at themselves in a
mirror
da noodle and uh little hearts coming
out
i still can't get over how you looked at
the tic-tac-toe
i mean i wanted to know what it was i
wanted to know what i wasn't supposed to
get confused with
all right d for delirious
u for unforgettable
h for hot as [ __ ] da noodle
thanks for the sticker buddy i love
noodles and stickers
oh killian mckellen yeah wow that name
[ __ ] rhymes yeah killing it with
killian mckellen with the
chilling with a felon and uh see i'm
this
pills i'm selling ooh traversing the
world like magellan
yeah way to go thanks uh thank you for
your super chat buddy
might not be a drastic genre change but
v for vendetta as a mew that is a
drastic
genre change but it could work i would
like that you could actually i could
actually see a beef or vendetta member
dental
vendetta musical i could actually see
someone doing that like some weird
off-broadway play yeah i could see that
i mean there's so much you could there
are so many themes you could write songs
about
and you could have a show-stopping
number where natalie portman gets her
headshot oh [ __ ] we got
more jobs yeah i know i was just like
let me
pull it back up john these are gonna be
the last of the super chats that we're
gonna read because we also got
maybe a stream lab one left yeah nissa
and john cesari horsemen
meet up at the gas station in splinter
dude john we gotta bring back that joke
about you banging anissa at the gas
station
that is a good idea i think that's going
to help
now anissa messaged me saying greg
please don't make that joke it makes me
very uncomfortable
and i said no anisa we're making that
joke i said you must be joking you must
be joking because i'm not going to stop
making that joke about you and john
meeting up at the gas station
in fact i'm tripping down greg your
instagram messaging me this
i can screenshot this and put it on
twitter and get you in trouble
and i said go for it let them try to
take me
down so anissa have fun banging jonathan
the conversation wasn't real guys
oh thank you but yeah eric thank you
buddy in splinter huh
interesting sarah campbell how's it
going sarah
sarah is that canadian it is canadian
sarah s for
shocking
h4 how you doing
i have no idea what's happening
or what anyone has suggest i just joined
the live i'd like to see the movie
frailty as a comedy what is frailty
i haven't seen it but it's a bill paxton
movie that he like wrote and directed i
think and it's like a horror it's like a
psychological
horror movie um and it's supposed to be
pretty good
so uh yeah all right john look it up do
that thing you do
yeah that thing you do remake that thing
you do but it's like a gritty drug adult
let's let's not leave people confused
here john
oh yeah yeah yeah a mysterious man
arrives at the offices of an fbi agent
an fbi agent and recounts his childhood
how his religious fanatic father
received visions
telling him to destroy people who are in
fact demons this could
that could very easily turn the
slapstick oh that one might you can make
the movie
like like frailty what's the christopher
walken trilogy prophet prophecy
uh oh yeah prophecy prophecy that could
be a comedy for sure
definitely and get christopher walken to
reprise his role as a wacky angel
well sarah appreciate your contribution
means a lot
heck yeah anise is back she says thank
you
you're welcome you don't need to thank
you
just say it yeah yeah and he says back
back back
the one where the real rejects does asmr
that could happen that could happen any
time we can do it
right now i want to do asmr to help
people
like poop when they're having a hard
time pooping
there there's got to be a but it's
probably an underserved market you can
tap into that
yeah yeah man there's there's got to be
i could fill a hole in this market
yeah charge a few bucks per
you know you save a lot of money on
colonic
irrigations and stuff you know you could
yeah be encouraged
into a more regular pooping schedule i
don't hate you and niece i love the [ __ ]
out of it we love the heck out of you
and isa
michael swift thanks michael swift you
michael
um m is for mighty eyes for
his uh itchy
c is for uh cool
h is for
[Laughter]
a is for um there's gotta be another a
adjective
that's good for people
and and anterior
anamorphic uh anamorphic yeah widescreen
e4 uh entertaining
l for uh you're a real looker thank you
michael
that's michael alice in zombieland i
like it
that would be a great red box rental
right there yes yes
that'd be a great red box run in the
style of like pride and prejudice in
zombies or something like that yeah
or or or fdr american badass i could see
it happening man you could see it
cause it's a brand new movie idea
that's not just a complete genre shift
it's a brand new movie right
here yeah because yeah there would be a
whole host of other creatures for alice
to interact with
and a whole different plot for her to
should we refresh this all right these
these have to be the last of the super
chats guys the last
five hours ahead of me the last of the
john is this right yeah i mean we gotta
go to the ceo do it john help me out man
you're you're good dog you're good dog
okay so anisa
all right last two of the super chats
you guys are killing it last
super super jon friends sewed me just
kidding yeah that's right sean would
never friends
never friend zone anyone he's a virgin
and he's holding out for you
yeah yeah i'm a virgin and no friends so
no friend zone
eric love to the discord fam
oh thank you guys do you this the
discord family touches my heart
a lot they'd be holding it down we
chimed in on our discord one time
if i didn't have five more hours of
editing right after this i would totally
go on there right now right after this
um but eric horseman and he said thank
you guys thank you guys for being part
of the discord thank you to everyone
who's contributed to the super chats
today they've been a blasty blast
we're not done with this stream we ain't
wait garth
you said oh i don't see mine in there
did we miss a garth let's check
let's let's do a quick scroll back uh i
don't see a guard where they start i see
the agoraphobic fanboy robert becerra
wolfpack gaming mark leach and nisa
near raj chase bradley
dominic uh all you have to do is control
f
all the searching you do for but we also
i'm killing birds with stones
we're all [ __ ] like oh i want to know
what tick-tock
movie is i'm killing birds with stones
by thanking everybody
in tandem and now who am i looking for
a he might be on the stream
on this on the stream lab yeah yeah we
might we might yeah there's no garth in
here so we will uh go to the stream labs
we'll go to the stream labs do a quick
refresher course and then we'll pop you
back in here
no need to freak out john why don't you
adjust that screen for the folks at home
any time g any time all right so we're
we got two these last two you said i
gave another super chat when we said no
more
thank you and he said oh thank you of
course the community and the chaos as we
got the chaos is bigger since the
[ __ ]
try going live okay bruce baine is back
and roose bain has seen the second last
one second last one because uh yeah
all right we're good we're good we good
we good all right
okay hear me out jackie chan defends an
unruly teenager in a serious court drama
while at the same time training the boy
to both defeat his own demons
as well as literally kick the [ __ ] out
of homophobia
oscar bait for the win i like it i like
it and it would
represent a real character arc for
jackie chan the human
but this isn't jackie chan isn't jackie
chan having homophobia accusations right
now
yeah doesn't he like shun his his
daughter
no more heroes for me no more heroes for
me i
well jay chan was literally my idol
growing up
problematic both jackie chan and mel
gibson
were like people i idolized problematic
faith
i idolized jackie chan my mom idolized
mel gibson now they're both just
[ __ ] their career down jesus christ
guys
no more heroes ryan gosling you are no
longer my current hero
make this movie with ryan gosling where
he kicks the [ __ ] out of homophobia
oh thank you roosevelt and garth
harkness
mcmurray oh here we go garth g
ford greg a for
alvin r for
rad rad
radical yeah that works t for
uh two
hot titties garth has captain america
in a serious world war two movie like
savinji
private ryan with no other super power
people
of gadgets just a gritty war movie with
cap kicking nazi
butt i am i wanted more
i want to oh the homophobia accusations
of chan are fake let's hope so
i hope so i wanted more cat that was
part of what disappointed me about first
avenger was immediately putting him into
our modern day time
i wanted more of captain america in in
the period in the period piece
in the period captain america having a
period that's my reboot
captain america in the period peace
drama
do you hear my captain america and
appear having a period joke
no oh he did oh because i was like i was
like that's weird i didn't hear any
laughter
oh sorry and so i was like maybe
do johnny's drunk let's do it again
let's do it again i was i got i got
distracted by olivia uh
talking about spamming and then i saw
deontay following up what are you
talking about this is the old ass chat
we're
looking at oh good great oh this has
that this hasn't scrolled for the last
hour and a half
got a good awesome proper chat over here
you guys can see captain america's
period
period piece
retell me the joke it's done the charm
is will definitely hit
i agree with you is what i'm trying to
tell you buddy garth i'm down as well
i yeah no i like i would all seriousness
i would love more period peace captain
america movies
and then john help you out what do i do
yeah out of a refreshment
so you just refresh it like normal and
then we click see all
we're gonna end in a few minutes guys
and soon we're gonna do a speed round of
all your crazy picks
the end is nigh okay look who we got
oh i spoke too soon we got two more
from anissa we got two more from another
you said discord fam
it means everything to me i love them
the discord fam loves you too you're one
of the leaders there
and she said i love you all thank you
for being my two faves we love the [ __ ]
out of you
you know how much i love you and john
will accept your rose
mm-hmm that's right i'm moving on to the
next episode we have honored
every super chat and every stream live
contribution we [ __ ]
did it we've done it once the editing
is not so time consuming then we'll get
on here for like six years
we can go back to the three-hour
livestream yeah and then we can go
hardcore
but you know we gotta we gotta you know
pair them down a little bit so people
missed the
next so we'll probably have to do
the next live stream on a friday or
thursday or maybe no live stream at all
depending on the crazy sketching on the
crazy
as we'll have to shoot for patreon to
get ahead on saturday and sunday because
we're gonna have
no time to shoot for anything else on
saturday at the very least
i would love it if we prep everything
and nothing comes out of dc family
except for like one thing to be like oh
that was a waste of time wow
there's a 30 second teaser for the
snyder of all the footage we've already
seen
great awesome thanks guys sex letters
just like
sorry guys i didn't see any of joss
whedon's i didn't know i didn't know
i didn't watch it oh that would be
awesome oh that was so
i didn't realize all this was already in
joss whedon wow all i had it back in was
darkseid who knew
you know i i mean they are hyping
dc phantom is is shaping up to be like
you know the
the comic-con at home that comic-con at
home wasn't so i i hope they don't
go out with a whimper all right
um let's see daily bugle in the style of
the office let's go to these comments
here
go to the comments um then we're gonna
say bye tango and slash
as a as a rock and roll buddy comedy
rocky but arnold's rocky just remake it
as an arnold movie instead
oh ruse bane on youtube as well back to
the future directed by christopher nolan
it's called tenant yeah i was going to
say
i literally typed it because it said
like tenants coming out september third
in select cities
and remember like and i was reading
articles that were like tenant is coming
out in 80
of america actually and i was like oh so
maybe there's one in california
so i filter my fandango app to be take
place within a 200 mile radius
zero tenant is not playing in a 200 mile
radius
so i will not be watching tennis
you know we can make it happen road trip
every road trip for
pretending we can go catch coaches
yeah like 80 of them like really it's
got to be
somewhere in california and 200 miles
nope nowhere inside maybe it's in baja
california
who the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
yeah
and then uh for us we'll never get
zodiac as a comedy
huh that's the office zodiac is the
office it's already funny
oh oh that's that 70s show is a drama
all right let's get a couple of good
ones uh eric that's really sweet of you
thank you eric
um bradley love you buddy anissa i love
you you know that
project power is a comedy well i love
the idea of us doing a 10 hour live
stream and we just keep changing the
subject
there's no way we can stay on topic we
would have to have a topic every
hour or every half hour or maybe we
could do a bell where the topic changes
every time you hit the bells that's true
oh that'd be fun yeah new topic all
right guys we're gonna oh we we're just
about to wrap this up and we got
one more super chat here oh [ __ ] we
haven't seen him
have you talked to him about your shoes
we haven't spoken in a while we should
get back on to talk
is that your fault or his fault um it's
probably my fault i mean i would just
assume
but uh you know i don't i i also
wouldn't just want to be like where's my
shoes you know because it's like you
know it's
super generous that he would even
consider i don't know if you read
the topic here geared towards ink who by
the way has a great instagram which i
see is blowing the [ __ ] up
his instagram's getting so many more
followers he does those awesome does
i haven't worn those yet because there
hasn't been any fabric i've said that
once
pandemic is over i have the first shoes
i will wear are the joker shoes
yes dear towards things sent me to the
next big social event
definitely and i'll have your card on
hand and be like actually from a guy
named geared towards inc
i don't think you understand this topic
he said a nightmare on elm street would
be dope
i think he thinks the topic is just
remake a movie
well you know he's leaving us open to
pick any genre we want
we already did nightmare announcer he
has a romantic comedy what other genre
could we do
there is no other joke there is no other
genre it would be an anime
elm street animated movie would be like
an actual [ __ ] animated movie
that would be cool if you could do yeah
i would love to see something like
because you could get so freaking trippy
[ __ ] bonkers yeah
reboot it as like an adult anime and
just make it bloody and gory if you did
like an
enemy out of all the like jokey anime
one reboots
elm street anime horror reboot would be
[ __ ]
disturbing you can do so much with the
because you know the human world stuff
would be messed up and the
totally dream that would be great i love
it you did it you're
talking to your choice i think well done
you brought us all together
in the spirit of anime went in on a high
note there
yeah all right yes thank you all for
joining us thank you for showing us the
love and support
thank you to everyone hashtag john is
beautiful love all the hashtags going on
there
thank you to everyone who contributed in
the super chats thank you to everyone
contributing the streaming lives and
thank you to everyone
who's just here hanging out with us yeah
um
if you're just chilling even yeah it's
it always takes us a little while to get
warmed up
and before we get there it doesn't help
with the flow at all
it just gets weirder it's just yeah it
doesn't kill you just makes you stranger
all right name call-outs let's keep
going while we're saying bye deontay
thank you claudia richard
anissa bradley sylvester eric tm
allison samuel ethan holgate
chase gardner judas
garth garth love your attitude horror
pic
tm and cobras i see your super chat but
we gotta go
buddy he's saying jaws as a nature
documentary
let me just flash that on the screen
really quick just so that you get your
time everybody got their
time this is a nature documentary that
sounds
funny yeah jaws but it's hardcore henry
from the sharks perspective let's do it
thank you buddy we're saying bye right
now mimi m alex j
o and b oh my god sorry for anyone's
name that miss richard michael b
i love you buddy thank you guys so much
guys
see you guys soon john hang up the phone
i'm hanging